[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be tackling
quite a controversial topic the harry
potter films versus the harry potter
books now i was first exposed to the
books they were the first thing that i
knew of harry potter and i think that
the general consensus among harry potter
fans is that the books are superior
mainly because they have so much more
detail than the original story the films
on the other hand took some liberties
some characters looked and even acted
differently plot points were omitted and
overall they were just much more
condensed but what did you expect six
hour long movies i love the harry potter
films i think they're great and while
the books did a lot of things better and
are in my opinion superior it doesn't
mean that there aren't things that the
films did better than the books
in today's video i'm going to be
touching on 20 things that i feel the
films did better than the books for the
die hard book fans try to watch this one
with an open mind this is going to be a
mix of longer and shorter points ranging
from single lines moments that were
included excluded all the way to major
shifts in the way that the films turned
out without further ado let's get
started number one hermione punching
malfoy in the prisoner of azkaban
hagrid's pet buckbeak is at one stage
sentenced to death malfoy's response to
this tragic sentencing is to mock hagrid
who was crushed after hearing the news
in the book harry ron and hermione all
try to get to malfoy to smack him but
hermione gets there first and slaps him
across the face in the film however
hermione sticks her wand into his neck
and ends up punching him shortly after
2. omission of quidditch quidditch is a
great game and certainly an integral
part of the harry potter story however
it does seem to pop up quite often and
i'm not sure that it would have done the
film's justice to show us quidditch
match after quidditch match what the
films did wonderfully was show just
enough quidditch to keep us interested
but not so much that it became
monotonous in order to achieve this
certain quidditch scenes were cut and i
think that this was a good call
3. comic relief at the end of the day
even a story like harry potter where the
stakes are so high like the sanctity of
the entire wizarding world comic relief
is certainly needed one thing that i
feel the films did particularly well was
pick and choose when a moment of humor
was appropriate one of my favorite
examples of this was when harry drank
felix felicis
4. mira of erised in the philosopher's
stone harry first encounters the mirror
of erised a magical mirror that shows us
the deepest most desperate desires of
our hearts in the book harry sees his
parents and his grandparents but in the
film harry just sees him and his parents
i feel that this was a positive change
as it provided a more intimate glance
into the longing that harry felt for his
parents
5. dobby's last words
dobby the lovable house elf that harry
grew to care for over the course of the
books and films eventually dies after
being struck with a knife thrown by
bellatrix lestrange
in the book dobby's last words were
harry potter mimicking his first ever
words to harry which made them fairly
significant however in the film dobby's
last words were much more heartbreaking
and i felt that they were more impactful
such a beautiful place to be with
friends dobby is happy to be with his
friend harry potter 6. the tale of the
deathly hallows the story of the
peverell brothers antioch cadmus and
ignotus as well as the deathly hallows
was in both the book and film it shows
the brothers conquering death obtaining
the hallows and later suffering their
own unique fates what the films did
wonderfully here however was included in
animation to accompany the story in a
style that emulated the adventures of
prince ahmed a 1926 animation by laut
reiniger in the film hermione reads the
tale aloud to ron harry and xenophilius
and it gives me chills every time i
watch it
7. the sorting hat the sorting hat known
for sorting students into their
respective houses and with the books and
films is actually cut out a little bit
from the films here's how in the books
the sorting hat would sing a song at the
start of every year the song in essence
discusses the meaning of each house and
what being sorted into that house says
about you the song though an integral
part of the books probably would have
been long and drawn out on the big
screen and i don't think that it was
really that important a lot of you may
not share my view on this point 8.
burning of the burrow this scene
actually didn't occur in the books at
all and i think that it was a good
addition to the films the scene in
question the burning of the burrow
occurs at christmas time and outlines
the death eaters attack on the weasley's
home after the good guys had finished
their christmas supper this scene was
effective in illustrating just how much
power voldemort and the death eaters had
at this stage
9. re-watchability the books though rich
with detail and extra pieces of
information do actually require a lot
more time to consume
this isn't really a point for the films
above the books as they're just
different but i do appreciate how easy
it is to pop on harry potter at the end
of a long day and absorb the whole thing
10. harry encountering snape in the
deathly hallows snape and mcgonagall
have an epic showdown however this scene
is quite different from book to film in
the book harry remains under the
invisibility cloak for the duration but
in the films harry shows his face to
snape entirely unafraid this gave harry
an opportunity to give snape a piece of
his mind where he delivers some of the
most powerful lines from the film series
how dare you stand where he stood a man
who trusted you
told him how it happened that night tell
them how you looked him in the eye and
killed him 11. mcgonagall and the
statues when the hogwarts professors and
good guys are fortifying hogwarts in
advance of the death eaters attack
mcgonagall casts a very cool looking
spell called pier totem locomotor which
animates the statues on the grounds
causing them to march off this happens
in both the book and film however the
film adds is a humorous line from
mcgonagall i've always wanted to use
that spell
12. eliminating spew
spew aka the society for the promotion
of elfish welfare is an aspect of the
books that didn't appear in the films in
the books hermione is on a veritable
crusade to ensure that house elves are
saved hermione starts the society after
she sees winky an elf who isn't in the
films being mistreated i think that the
films pretty clearly illustrate that
house elves are mistreated and i just
don't think that it would have made
sense to include it especially given how
condensed the films are
13. the casting this is a bit of a cheap
one because obviously books don't have
casting we're just forced to use our
imaginations to create these characters
in our minds however with that said i
think the casting for harry potter was
absolutely incredible hagrid snape
dumbledore both actors hermione harry
draco they were all perfectly cast and
though my imagination did a pretty good
job here these actors were excellent i
guess this isn't really a point for how
the movies are better but i think it's
worth mentioning
14. holiday ambiance the harry potter
films though appropriate for any
occasion in my mind are particularly
impactful at christmas and this is
because of the holiday ambiance that
comes with them
filmmakers did a particularly good job
at setting the scene for the holidays
through music set creation and whatever
else was involved in creating this
magical holiday environment again this
is not necessarily a quip at the books
but just something the films did really
well
15. harry and sirius the story of the
marauders is more or less crossed over
in the films but that didn't stop
filmmakers from independently
introducing each of the marauders in
their own capacity later in life this
included sirius black who forms a strong
believable bond with harry over the
course of the films
one big difference in their relationship
from book to film however is that in the
books sirius never calls harry james
when sirius calls harry james his
father's name it illustrates just how
much like his father harry had become
and it was certainly something that i
appreciated 16. dumbledore and
voldemort's jewel
now the epic showdown between voldemort
and dumbledore inside the ministry
atrium is included in both the book and
the film it was a jewel of epic
proportions good against evil light
against dark and it totally overshadowed
all of the boring stalemates that harry
had with voldemort now as wonderful as
describing a battle is i think that this
is the type of thing that is better
suited to the big screen it was an
impressive looking jewel with jets of
green and red flying everywhere and
ended up being the most impressive jewel
in the whole story as descriptive as a
book can be let's be real it was epic on
screen
17. hedwig's sacrifice during the battle
of the seven potters the order of the
phoenix are transporting harry from the
dursley residents and they end up having
to protect him from the death eaters in
both the book and the film hedwig dies
here however in the book hedwig simply
dies in a cage by harry's side while
riding on hagrid's motorcycle in the
films hedwig's death is more grandiose
as hedwig ends up dying trying to
protect harry dying a hero's death and
inadvertently signifying the loss of
innocence in the story
18. hermione using obliviate now being
harry potter's best friend doesn't come
without risk and certainly not in a
world with voldemort this meant that
when the death eaters and voldemort were
rising to power hermione knew that she
would need to take action to ensure that
her parents would remain safe this
action ended up being obliviating her
parents that is wiping all memories of
her from their minds in the book
hermione sort of mentions this in
passing but in the film we're provided
with an extremely dark depressing
dramatic scene with hermione aiming her
wand at her parents uttering the words
obliviate and watching her face
disappear from the family portraits this
was an excellent addition to the films
19. the battle of hogwarts the battle of
hogwarts the final showdown between the
good and the bad guys is in both the
harry potter books and films however the
book seems to focus quite a lot on harry
during the battle and less on the other
characters what the film does well here
is show us all of the other participants
in the battle and what they got up to
this provided us with some extra action
as well as a better perspective on the
magnitude scale of the battle
20. the development of the films this is
another one that isn't necessarily a
quip at the books but instead praises
the films for something they did well as
time passed as characters aged and as
stakes increased the harry potter films
underwent a transformation that was
evident from film to film
the innocent childlike first installment
the philosopher's stone gradually
plunges into darkness and we eventually
end up with the extremely dark serious
deathly hallows part 2 filled with
heartbreak and turmoil though the films
were directed by a few different people
there was certainly an element of
continuity from film to film in this
respect and each director did a good job
at slowly setting a darker and darker
tone that's it for this video there are
certainly more things but here are 20
decent ones that stuck out to me what do
you guys think what do you think the
films did better than the books or did i
miss comment down below until next time
remember it is the quality of one's
convictions that determine success not
the number of followers
[Music]